[Music]
hello everybody I'm per Mille and I'm
Ryan we're the founders a perfect day
and we're excited to share our story
with you today I was born and raised in
India and I moved to the US four years
ago in 2013 my parents moved from India
to America in the 1980s I was born and
raised in Connecticut where I had a
fairly typical American childhood here's
the funny thing we didn't actually know
each other when we started the company
four years ago when we met for the first
time we realized that we had two things
in common both of us
wanted to have impact on a global scale
and we loved food we both grew up eating
real meat and dairy products enjoying
their delicious indulgent taste
who doesn't love a rich ice cream or a
melty gooey cheese these tastes are
deeply ingrained in our memories but as
we got older we started to develop an
awareness of the big picture we started
to learn about global climate change and
ask questions about how our lifestyle
might be contributing to the problems
eventually we came to learn that our
diet in particular was having a greater
impact than we might have wanted and so
around the beginning of college we both
decided to go vegetarian now this wasn't
terribly difficult
we basically replaced all the meat we
were eating with eggs and dairy you sort
of cling to the only animal products you
have left but eventually our commitment
to the big picture led us to realize
that eggs and dairy are part of the very
same problematic system as meat and so a
few years later we painfully made the
transition to being fully vegan this
meant we were no longer eating any meat
nor eggs nor most difficult for us dairy
can you imagine
say goodbye to cream in your coffee
butter on your toast cheese in all its
delightful forms it thought I actually
hated my life back then
we were trying to do the right thing but
it was so hard when we changed to a
vegan diet that single decision
completely changed our relationship with
food we can no longer find good options
to eat all of the dairy alternatives
that were available felt like they were
held together with glue instead of real
food and the worst part we can no longer
enjoy the social elements of just
sharing food with family and friends
because none of them wanted to adopt a
vegan diet the diet that is good for the
planet
and good for the animals forces you to
compromise it forces you to compromise
on flavor on nutrition and on the
overall experience and that was the
inspiration for us well we started by
taking a step back and looking at how
the food system works today for animal
products and when you do that you
quickly realize two things the first is
that animal agriculture is extremely
inefficient the way we produce animal
protein today is posing a huge challenge
to the environment I'm not going to give
you the numbers or hit you over the head
with the statistics you can easily look
those up but know that animal
agriculture is posing a grave threat to
our planet as it is why because there
are 70 billion land animals today but
they feed only 7 billion people
most of the food we grow as a society
goes towards feeding those 70 billion
and only a small part of it is converted
into useful food for us it's crazy
the natural resources like water and
land that are required to produce these
products at scale are becoming more and
more scarce day by day but the demand is
only growing and that brings us to the
second troubling trend you see it's hard
enough to produce sufficient animal
protein to meet the demand of today what
about tomorrow despite a growing
awareness of these challenges we find
that demand for animal protein is still
only increasing all over the world and
as you've probably heard a hundred times
today the world population is expected
to surpass nine and a half billion by
2050 interesting to me is that many of
these new people are going to be in
developing economies we're at the larger
and wealth
middle-class emerges typically one of
the first things that these empowered
new consumers start to spend their money
on its animal protein if you combine
these two factors you have a perfect
storm not only do we need to produce far
more protein but we have to do so in a
way that is fundamentally less damaging
than what we do today now sure the easy
answer would be for everyone to just
stop eating animal products and switch
to alternatives but we can tell you from
firsthand experience that's easier said
than done
let's ultimately why we've set out to
support the evolution of our food system
as a whole by creating a more secure
environmentally friendly and nutritious
source of protein without the use of a
single animal in the entire process okay
so how do you make animal protein
without animals I remember I had that
exact question in my mind one day at
work back in 2014 at the time I was
developing antibodies and other
medicines using the tools of
biotechnology and I had this sort of aha
lightbulb moment when I realized that
the antibodies I was making already were
animal proteins made without animals
which led to the question could this
very same technology be used to make
high quality protein for the food
industry that wouldn't have these kind
of impact on the environment and on
animals and all these other different
things that's ultimately when I met
param all in 2014 what surprised me so
much about us is that he had come to the
exact same realization through his work
in biomedicine and that's why we teamed
up and joined forces to start perfect
day we had recognized an untapped
opportunity to create protein using
these technologies
the key is fermentation fermentation is
the art and science of just converting
nutrients from one form into the other
we've created a type of yeast that
converts sugar into milk protein that is
the key to our technology and our entire
platform the cool thing is we're taking
sugar something that the world is pretty
good at producing and we're converting
it into high-quality nutritious protein
that the world is demanding
we've designed our process to fit in to
existing infrastructure that's found all
over the globe and we're working with
the industry to scale up and we will be
out there in a big way pretty soon if
you're wondering what our process
actually looks like
imagine a beer brewery if you walk into
our production process in the future
there'll be these beautiful giant
stainless steel tanks inside it will be
yeast that's converting sugar into milk
protein for human use our platform
allows us to make any protein out there
but we chose dairy proteins for two
reasons its nutrition and its
functionality dairy protein is the most
nutritious source of protein available
to humans today it contains all the
essential amino acids required it's
super digestible it helps in everything
from muscle recovery to halting stunted
growth and children and it also delivers
a ton of calcium to your body on the
functionality side these proteins are
the reason dairy is so amazing when you
take a scoop of yogurt and put it in
your mouth that body that creaminess
that mouthfeel it's all the protein the
reason milk is white in color is because
of the protein the reason when you take
a slice of pizza from the entire pie
that beautiful stretch that you see when
you're removing that piece of pizza it's
the protein if you tried to make cheese
using plant protein the best thing you
can actually make today is tofu now
don't get me wrong I like tofu
but it ain't cheese our plan is to
create a new way for the world to make
dairy proteins so that we can all go on
eating our favorite food products just
healthier kinder and greener than ever
before if we can create proteins that
are more sustainable and more humane and
better for everyone involved then the
animal equivalent but still deliver on
taste and price and convenience then the
dilemma disappears the choice that's
best for our bodies and for animals and
the planet can become the default answer
for consumers because we're no longer
asking anyone to compromise and that is
what separates us from the pack if you
look at plant proteins they're just not
functional and they're not nutritious
that's why food manufacturers when they
use plant proteins to make any product
they're really
promisingly an emulsifier starches
hydrocolloids gums things you really
don't want in your food animal protein
super functional super nutritious but
it's not gonna scale it's just not
sustainable we have created a solution
that's the best of both worlds
it contains the nutrition of dairy
because it is dairy protein but because
it's produced in a new way it has the
heart and soul of plant-based proteins
it's way more sustainable a true win-win
solution for us this isn't a solution
for next generation the technology is
possible today and the world urgently
needs this as soon as possible the dairy
industry itself may be reaching a
ceiling we've heard from people that
work inside the dairy industry and are
concerned whether dairy is going to be
able to reach meat protein demand by
2025 we're starting to hit the
biological limits of what we can make
cows do meanwhile consumers are in the
midst of a massive global shift away
from animal products animal protein in
particular parallel and I are two
examples of this but you've probably
noticed this in your everyday life too
we've read that more than 60% of
Millennials are trying to reduce the
amount of animal protein in their diet
if not going all the way to vegetarian
or vegan and that may sound like great
news and it is don't get me wrong but
it's nowhere near the kind of critical
mass that we're going to need to really
address the problems that we're talking
about here finally food companies are
always looking for innovative
ingredients that can bring new
experiences to food our approach enables
food innovation while solving some of
the world's greatest challenges and that
might just be why food companies are
lining up to be among the first to work
with our ingredients and we can't wait
to share it with them when we first
started on this journey we were obsessed
with making products like cheese yogurt
ice cream finished goods but on the way
we learned that dairy proteins offer
functionality to a wide variety of
products not just fresh dairy this mean
that if we zoom out a little bit and
take more of an ingredient centric
approach perfect day dairy proteins and
therefore our impact will be able to
extend to products in every aisle of the
grocery store not just the dairy case
four years ago we were trying to have
impact by changing our individual diets
two years ago we would have been happy
with the impact of just launching a
single product on the retail store but
today
now that we've embraced an ingredient
strategy and we've taken a broader look
at how the food industry actually works
we're truly blown away by the scale of
impact we can have disrupting a nearly
trillion-dollar market and looking
forward we're really excited to partner
with the industry to come up with
creative solutions to some of the
greatest problems challenging our
generation like how do all of us
continue to enjoy the cheese on our
pizza without having to compromise on
the planet or our own nutrition or our
own experience the world is changing and
the food system needs to change and
evolve with it and the two of us are
super excited that we have the rare
opportunity to help drive that evolution
in the field of dairy thank you
you